[Musica]
una presentazione così era anch'io
curioso di vedere chi usciva poi la
condizione non è felice dopo così tanti
interventi di ritrovarsi a parlare
interventi stimolanti un po la
condizione del dell'ottavo marito di liz
taylor la prima sera di nozze e
difficile proporre qualcosa di
interessante nuovo per coerenza
cercherò di farla di farla veloce e mi
contatta mattia carinissimo per
invitarmi a parlare di velocità e
politica avendo letto di ciò su una mia
intervista su una rivista del settore
cioè rolling stones e io mi occupo oggi
prevalentemente oggi mi occupo di
comunicazione del gruppo team e sono
quello che ha fatto quel ballerino che
balla con spiderman con star wars e con
stelle olio con la musica di mina il
ballerino contro tutti tra poco parlerà
con topolino
prima di questa roba qui
mi sono occupato di produzioni
televisive per 15 anni ho fatto 5 mila
ore di prodotto televisivo tipo
passaparola sarabanda a top of the pops
900 via dicendo vento cinque delegati è
lo dico semplicemente per raccontare che
prima ancora ho fatto politica fino a 25
anni più o meno guidato un movimento di
70 mila ragazzi ero un craxiano di ferro
dal 92 in poi con un tempismo di fiuto
tattico opportunistico
notevole è praticamente sono in sostanza
un reperto archeologico della prima
repubblica di quel mondo che era diviso
tra chi stava da una parte del muro di
berlino chi dall'altra
e chi ci è rimasto sotto cioè noi quindi
io sono un fossile vivente
sostanzialmente di quell'epoca e quindi
ho raccontato tutto ciò per dire che del
tema di cui parlerò stasera qualche
pratica c'era anche se oggettivamente
viviamo in un'epoca dove non avere
nessuna competenza di un tema ti rende
candidabile più o meno ogni incarico
quindi dicevamo di fossili e velocità
allora volevo fare vedere la mia
scrivania si cominciava di qui eccola
qua questa è la mia scrivania e qui
vedete ci sono dei fossili ce ne sono
anche altri e chi entra nel mio ufficio
dice questo cosa ci avrà in testa
guardando alla scrivania io guardando
nella sua testa dico e quando vedi una
scrivania vuota cosa pensi ma il punto è
il tengo quei fossili che sono roba di
circa 50 milioni di anni fa o altri di
circa 450 milioni di anni fa perché mi
diverte
sincronizzare le mie agende isteriche
con la certificazione certa di quella
roba che è stata 400 e 450 milioni di
anni fa e rispetto invece al concetto di
velocità
cerco di non dimenticare mai che noi
siamo tutti belli così tranquilli su una
terra che gira velocemente a 1.700
chilometri all'ora
che poi gira sua volta oltre che su se
stessa
intorno al sole al 100 mila chilometri
all'ora che a sua volta sistema solare
gira intorno alla galassia un milione di
chilometri all'ora in una galassia che
va a una velocità infinita verso il bo e
e anche questo c'entra con quello che
proverò a dire la prima politicizzazione
della velocità la facciamo noi in italia
con un movimento il futurismo che
incomincia a parlarti di questi bolidi
di questo euforia rispetto a questa
modernità che arriva e la vede dal punto
di vista dello spettatore fermo che vede
i fotogrammi che si che sfrecciano non
lo fa dalla parte capovolta cioè dalla
punto di vista dell'osservatore che
invece vede le persone scappare
dietro però ogni isteria produce come
come un teorema di archimede il suo
contro quindi lustri dopo ci ritroviamo
contro il logorio della vita moderna che
è una posizione che si contrappone a
quella andava a cento all'ora del nostro
gianni morandi e che voleva correre
velocemente verso la sua passione
poi arrivano i filosofi dell'anti
modernismo quel genio di paul virilio
simulatori di prossimità tv web
portatili che sfruttano stavolta
l'impostura dell'immediatezza in
un'epoca in cui l'ideologia della
interattività sovrana rende la nostra
visione del mondo più tel oggettiva che
oggettiva come persiste nell'essere come
opporre una resistenza efficace la
repentina
di realizzazione del mondo meraviglioso
un genio ma prima di lui quest altro
genio qui de dominici sul 1970 fa
un'opera il tempo lo sbaglio lo spazio
sull'immortalità lui dice state
sbagliando tutti tutto per rincorrere il
miglioramento della vostra specie cioè
per migliorare la vostra vita per
migliorare la qualità state velocizzando
tutto cercando di ingannare il tempo
mettendoci più spazio per questo mette i
pattini al protagonista è anche al cane
del protagonista cioè voi cercate di
ingannare il tempo facendoci più cose
dentro ma la fine è identica
è un po come nelle partite di calcio
attuali no sono sempre 90 minuti ma si
guarda partita di calcio di oggi ci sono
quattro partite di calcio degli anni 30
per quantità di moto che ci si consuma
dentro però i responsabili per de
dominici sostanzialmente sono questi due
nell'evoluzione della ruota che portano
questo mondo ad andare veloce veloce
quali sono le altre critiche della
modernità nei secoli
questo è un boss tra il 1500 1525 questo
quadro ci sono i sette vizi capitali
vedete nella pupilla cioè dio e
nell'iride ci sono le sette scene dei
vizi capitali
i peccati che l'uomo compie è
sostanzialmente chi gli dice 500 anni fa
sta attento cave cave deus sfide te ce
stai attento perché dio ti vede quando
combini quelle cose
occhio poi arriva arrivano secoli
successivi arriva spinosa si salta la
superstizione finalmente l'uomo è libero
è libero di non avere un occhio che lo
guarda guarda sono tutte sciocchezze
gestisce di la tua vita e ti ritrovi
al posto del di quella pupilla ce n'è
un'altra che ti vede tutto il giorno e
quindi se non ti vedo io dio ti vedo io
tecnica e tu dirai è stato meraviglioso
questa cavalcata di tecnologia marconi
bel tim bernes lee i dati compressi per
poi ritrovarci finalmente ad utilizzare
in un bel collegamento in diretta
dall'honduras in giucas casella che ti
fa la pipì in diretta perché questi sono
i vantaggi dell'esserci sempre
costantemente altra visione di
liberazione del dalla da una fede dalla
sede del dolore new religion prega vi
per liberarti da un male dell'anima del
fisico la religione contemporanea new
religion per damiani è la sostituzione
di quello stiam non ostia scientifica la
sostituzione dell'altare nella croce che
esce sulla strada e si sostituisce la
sostituzione dell'altare con il bancone
sono luoghi negativi ma assolutamente no
non si può essere antimodernisti
rispetto a questa velocità di evoluzione
ditelo a sarà grippo ditelo galassi di
tela shanti non si può essere contro
soprattutto perché se non si e
testardamente tenaci sull'evoluzione
della modernità e della tecnica non si
esce dalle epoche perché dall'età della
pietra non si è usciti per esaurimento
della pietra di rocce e di sassi
e parliamo oggi del lodge del nostro
imminente domani io tra le varie cose
oltre alla comunicazione
seguo tutto il mondo delle nostre
ricerche e il clima è complicato l'altro
giorno dovevo presentarmi al board e
fargli un quadro rispetto alle ricerche
che avevo dell'imminente domani e del
paese tendenzialmente ti presenti con
buone e cattive notizie e io ho detto
parto dalle cattive notizie non ci sono
buone notizie
e qual è uno dei punti fondamentali di
questa sistema di crisi le provato a
sintetizzarlo così che è il motivo per
cui mattia mi ha chiamato quando ha
letto questa intervista
noi siamo in un'età di usura di classi
dirigenti che corrisponde un po la
cultura dei talent che è secondo me non
è di casa una cultura meritoria perché
ha fatto più per il merito la cultura
dei talent che cento dibattiti su
etica evoluzione delle classi dirigenti
però le persone si stufano presto e
quanto più i tempi sono complessi e
quanto è più facile che è chiedano
cencia insegne e quindi questa curva su
in maniera esponenziale
al contempo la curva di formazione delle
classi dirigenti opposta perché viviamo
in tempi sempre più complicati sempre
più verticali con sempre più saperi
rispetto ai quali esercitarsi per non
dire delle sciocchezze qui pedale è
complicato e quindi a parità di tempo
produce meno persone a meno che non
siano persone improvvisate e quindi c'è
il rischio che da qualche parte del
mondo le persone si stufino di questo
[Musica]
improvvisazione siano disposti a cedere
diritti che sono sempre più inflazionati
perché io quando non sono in grado di
darti delle risposte concrete di stampo
delle promesse ma le promesse leva e
accumulare in un cassetto di cose che
poi non incasserà e mai e quindi si sta
passando da una sorta di capitalismo
democratico ha un rischio potenziale
prospettico e di capitalismo autocratico
che già in giro per il mondo si sta
mostrando e qui cosa sta portando questa
velocità
allora innanzitutto una voce abbastanza
comune di questo diffuso modo di pensare
che il potere chiami immoralità secondo
me è una cosa abbastanza banale pensare
che non è così e che in realtà è
l'esercizio del potere non è mai
innocente non è mai innocente da prima
del signore degli anelli si coniuga con
la necessità di ricambio continuo il
potere noi innocente perché ti cambia
pensate come immagine in metafora un
luogo molto potente che la centrale
nucleare centrale nucleare
se tu vai vicino al nucleo
ti cambia senza che tu te ne accorga e
quindi non ci puoi stare tanto vicino ci
deve andare ma ti devi togliere quindi
vai al potere ci stai un po come te ne
vai subito però questa cosa non si
concilia con l'esperienza
perché se miei figli uno che l'ho appena
presa per strada e lo mando a gestirmi
nucleo della centrale nucleare
forse abbiamo un problema e da noi
poi si supplisce all'esperienza spesso
con la consulenza che è l'ignoranza di
qualcun altro che spesso ti parla di
cose che non ha mai fatto sono un po
come quelli che con aria contrita ti
spiegano come si allacciano le stringhe
ma però te lo fanno indossando un
mocassino e tu sei vagamente
insospettito oppure come tutti quei
tecnici che si palesano come
indipendenti bravissimi ma se sono così
indipendenti e così bravi ti viene il
sospetto che come lavoravano prima per
alcuni migliori dopo la piccola
parentesi da civil servant torneranno a
lavorare per coloro che rappresentavano
prima e poi c'è il problema della
casualità dei quadri ma se ti arrivano
le persone così velocemente
all'improvviso in un mondo dove
difficile conoscere le persone che ti
stanno accanto anche dopo vent'anni o
sapere cosa ha fatto sua figlia ieri
sera semplice sinceramente affidare la
vita del tuo paese il tuo futuro a
questa casualità può essere un po
pericoloso
e poi questa velocità di questi tempi
eccitati convive con una dimensione di
vanità e di ottusità della classe
dirigente che è chiamata a sentirsi
indispensabile e che davvero una forma
di ottusità grossa quella di sentirsi
insostituibili in un mondo che oggi in
un'epoca che addirittura a due papi poi
come ultima cosa dovresti chiedere di
essere morali ma spesso rispetta la
moralità trovi invece una grande
categoria di moralisti che sono
tutt'altra cosa
quelle persone che sono capacissime di
essere violentissima mente calviniste
con il prossimo ma terribilmente
cattoliche con loro stesse
quindi tutto questo produce antipolitica
che poi è semplicemente la politica di
qualcun altro e fiducia nei meccanismi
della democrazia che rimane quel sistema
in cui credi finché non vince qualcuno
che non sei tu
pessimismo ma io non ce ne ho credo
sinceramente che viviamo nel migliore
dei mondi possibili e che comunque ho
cresciuto due figlie senza raccontargli
per la prima volta nella storia della
genealogia della mia famiglia
una bugia alla domanda di come sarebbe
stato il domani perché siamo la prima
generazione dove al nostro domani non
bussava in maniera imminente una guerra
o qualche altra tragedia e quindi visto
che i problemi sono solo soluzioni che
aspettano di essere risolte trovate sono
soluzioni timide penso che sia un mondo
che continua a produrre rutilanti
complessità e anche codardi e perché
mentre ci impegniamo ad avere una
cultura da bio a km zero non ce ne frega
assolutamente niente di utilizzare
strumenti o di indossare vestiti a
diritti 0 beh in una società così
contraddittoria e così veloce
bisogna continuare a pensare di essere
una delle generazioni più fortunate di
quelle che ha calcato questo mondo e
bisogna accarezzare per bene le nostre
fortune e volerle molto bene perché le
fortune sono magie molto viziate che
all'improvviso ti abbandonano e poi è
difficile riprenderla
[Applauso]
[Musica]